There are many services out
there that let you create
clusters on demand in minutes.
This allows you to pay for a cluster
only when you need the resources.
Amazon's offering is called
Elastic MapReduce, or EMR for short.
It works well with other
AWS services such as S3 and
automatically installed applications
such as Hive, Presto, and Spark.
Google has a service too.
Cloud Data Proc allows you to analyze
data with MapReduce, Hive, Spark,
and others.
Microsoft also has a Hadoop
cloud service, HDInsight.
Which one you choose
depends on your budget and
how well it works with other
cloud services you're using.
For this lesson you'll
be using Amazon's EMR.